My name is Diakalola Amujam. I am a recent psychology graduate from Ireland. I am also an aspiring clinical psychologist. Dr. Marion's book, The Clinical Psychologist Collective, has been so helpful to me on this journey to becoming a clinical psychologist. As I plan to continue postgraduate studies in the UK, I found it extremely useful that this book provided in-depth information on the UK. the declineside application process. I enjoyed reading about the experiences of both qualified and training clinical psychologists. The various narratives were my favorite part of the book, as everyone's story was different and it provided amazing insights into the clinical psychology journey.
I would definitely recommend this book to anyone interested in psychology and aspires to become a clinical psychologist. Hi, welcome along to Inner Work. I'm Dr. Marianne Trent, a qualified clinical psychologist. Now this week's main podcast episode is about neurofeedback and that's with Dr. Madeline Rohntree. And it kind of got me thinking about the idea that we're unfinished versions of ourselves. And I, yeah, I'm always striving to think about how we can make changes. So I think it's not part of the kind of whole Stephen Bartlett kind of optimization of everything narrative. But actually, if there's things, that we recognise that we maybe would welcome being a bit different or feeling a bit different
about, then that can be really useful as a, even just as a starting point. And I think when we're beginning to think about accessing therapy, then it's those things, you know, what would be your goals? What would you change about yourself? And I guess some of the kind of trickier ethics of neurofeedback are, you know, is it okay that we are thinking about changing other people, you know, changing our children, changing the way that they are. And there's been some kind of ethical discussion around that that I seem to remember when I read Sieben Fisher's book and the book by Bessel van der Kolk as well. But yeah, you know, not being finished, it's that idea that our brain has always got this ability to learn. Our habits can change.
our, you know, relational patterns can change. We don't necessarily need to accept this status quo of how it is right now. And I think that's different than saying that you are broken or that someone else is broken. It's having that belief in the ability to change, to adapt, to, I guess, as Madeline was saying, to find that balance, to come back to, I guess a better, a better frequency for you. where you resonate differently with less trauma, I think, in more of an adaptive way. And you might well have written yourself off for things or thought there's nothing I can do about that.
I know a few weeks ago I spoke about wanting to book a pelvic physio women's health assessment. I am delighted to report that I have taken action, and I'm already seeing changes from some of the recommendations and the physio exercises that the physio gave me. If you'd like to learn more about that, drop me a comment and I will maybe think about making a video about what all of that involved. I think that came about for me
because I kind of wasn't prepared to just have that, this is me moment, really, from, you know, the greatest showman. I was like, this is my opinion of what I am like right now, but I would welcome the qualified expert opinion on whether this is just something that I need to put up with. So I think, yeah, get curious.
Maybe don't take your own opinion, unless you are an expert qualified opinion, maybe seek other opinions about whether it might be worth exploring things. And I guess even if you're scoping things out with people around you, that might be a bit of an echo chain, but they might also have the same thoughts and feelings as you. So that's why I think booking a session in with someone who is an expert in that field. So it might be physiotherapy. It might be a cancer. It might be a therapist. It might be a psychologist. Someone that has different experiences that you're going to get a more balanced opinion from,
I think can be transformational because then you get the benefit of, of feeling. feeling validated, of feeling understood. And then when you have that, it sort of rallies this inner drive to help you to stay on your track to make changes. I would love your thoughts on this. What behaviour or feeling states would you want to change? Maybe we'll get a little bit cheeky. Is there anything you'd change about someone else?
You know, if you could strap on some neurofeedback electrodes and be like, let's get rid of that thing, what would it be? I would love your thoughts. Thank you so much for being a listener, a watcher for inner work. I will look forward to bringing you the next episode, which will be along next week. Thank you again. I'll see you soon. Take care. My name's Jana and I'm a trainee, psychological well-being practitioner. I read the clinical psychologist collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one. And this kind of filled me of confidence that, no, I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself.
So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist, I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay. But trust me, you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.